If 2020 was anything, it was a worldwide slap
in the face.
Still, you'd think that some people would
be used to that sort of thing by now.
The cast of "Jackass," for example, has made
a pretty solid living getting slapped in all
sorts of places.
For most of us, 2020 made a simple trip to
the grocery store feel like a death-defying
stunt worthy of Knoxville and his pain-loving
cohort.
If anyone was going to show up to the last
18 months with a subtle air of experience
and the collectively callused sense of dignity
necessary to keep soldiering on, it would have been them.
Right?
Kind of.
In a recent interview with The Nine Club,
Jason "Wee Man" Acuña got candid about the
process of creating the latest, and theoretically
final, installment of a story on par with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe or The Skywalker
Saga.
We are speaking, of course, of the "Jackass"
epic.
"Jackass Forever" famously suffered from its
share of production setbacks due to interpersonal
drama, but the COVID-19 pandemic proved to
be a predictably immense thorn in the movie's side.
It turns out that making a movie about a bunch
of guys traveling and messing with strangers
gets a little more difficult when said guys
can't travel or be around other people.
Speaking on the subject of "Jackass Forever"
and the general "Jackass" body of work, The
Nine Club host Chris Roberts expressed his
admiration for the cast's relaxed attitude
with regards to mortal peril.
That includes, of course, playing tetherball
with a hive of killer bees.
Or pulling a real-life Fonz and attempting
an ill-fated leap over a family of circling sharks.
Acuña was quick to point out that "Jackass
4" was shot with a different energy, and for
that he blames - or credits - the global pandemic.
He said,
"This next one, because of COVID ... we couldn't
fly and mess with people and all that.
I'll just say this: it's backyard 'f--k each
other up' stuff.
That's all it is.
And that's all I can say about it."
Faced with that ominous teaser, Roberts became
concerned that a "different energy" might
connote a lack of serious injuries sustained
by the cast.
What would a fourth "Jackass" feature be without
the attendant emergency room visits and the
ensuing barrage of insurance claims, after
all?
Rest assured, Wee Man confirmed that he absolutely
hurt himself filming "Forever."
Roberts didn't even finish asking "did you
ever get badly hurt?" before Acuña kicked
in, emphatically repeating the word "yes."
He even went so far as to promise that, compared
to previous outings with the "Jackass" crew,
"this one hurt more."
If that's not a guaranteed good time at the
theater, nothing is.
"Jackass Forever" became part of the most
ill-timed class of productions in film history,
as the crew attempted to begin shooting in
the halcyon days of the first quarter of 2020.
At this time, the pandemic was in its infancy,
and very few people were even taking the early
reports of a novel coronavirus in escalating
circulation seriously.
As we all remember, that changed quickly,
and films in the midst of photography like
"Jackass Forever" had to respond with due
haste.
Many shut down completely, but to hear Wee
Man tell it, "Jackass Forever" took a different approach.
Acuña said,
"We started before COVID, we took the COVID
break, and Paramount used us as the guinea
pig to see how studios could get back into
filming.
And we had to do all the tests, and do it
all.
And they're like, 'Well, 'Jackass' guys did
it.'
It was then used as a tool to get the other
ones going."
From how Acuña tells it, it sounds like Paramount
was more than willing to let the "Jackass"
crew serve as a proof of concept, putting
the cast's taste for danger up to viral scrutiny
to see if a production could carry on under
a regime of rigorous testing and social distancing.
Acuña went on to say the original goal was
to make "Jackass" fun again, which he attributes
to the cast's now-advanced age.
As luck would have it for fans of self-inflicted
pain, the pandemic busted up that vision for
whatever reason.
"Okay, let's make it fun!
But no, Covid made it--made us, COVID made
us beat each other up again."
And why wouldn't it?
"Jackass Forever" is slated to hit theaters
on October 22, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.